I'd like to welcome onto this coming a
good friend of mine
no man welcome onto the show hello very
good friends in the last seven days
yes when we met though you did not know
that I was Samuel Leeds
I don't know I was short with you in the
film I remember thinking this person
yeah it was like I wasn't going through
it in Patania when you said there's
person gonna look in your poverty and
I'm gonna some black so I'm like I said
I don't want to waste your time and I
want to waste my time I'll show you
around if you like it and see ya where
we go yeah why don't you just give a
little bit of background to yourself cuz
your view obviously the owner of a
letting agent in general tell us a
little about what it is that you do and
how long you been doing it and I've been
doing it since I'm the management agent
he's I've been doing it for five years
now yeah in my background I've been a
long lady for 18 years Wow okay I see
you've got a lot of experience in profit
oh yes
and I'm good yeah Sheffield market
because I don't know if you knew this
but I I was selected to come to
Sheffield last week and it was like a
random place I didn't know where I was
going to be I pulled a city out of the
Hat hmm my name is Sheffield and then
just drove to Sheffield to be a property
entrepreneur in Sheffield
so tell us a little about Juke Sheffield
is a good a good property monkeys doing
well and Sheffield what's going us
always and obviously the university is
increasing getting larger and larger and
we have more international student
coming over to check out this study from
all over the world so the renting market
is increasingly very high demand
Sheffield which is good yeah and what
you do then on a day-to-day basis what's
your job my job is to rent poverty so
everyone student commercial we deal with
commercial property as well and
professionals so you're a a letting
agent you're only letting go you say you
rent rooms out the web right now we're
sat inside one of one of my new
apartment
yes which secured for me through the
landlord when we first spoke and I told
you the idea of renting get out a
serviced accommodation as a corporate
less was that something that you were
familiar with this is something that you
were excited about were you worried
about it what was going on in your mind
I was familiar with it also I had some
quite few people approached me and I
heard some bad story with her and I
heard some good story yeah so I was
willing to try yeah have you ever done
it before would you ever had anybody
with this apartment block or another
plant block actually take on a property
on a corporate let serviced
accommodation basis no you've never had
it never had you're the first so what
did I say that made you confident and
comfortable because bear in mind I was I
was acting as Lucas Ruby yes and I
talked and I told you that I only just
set the company up last week if you do
you remember yes just because you were
asking for two years I said I can't do
that because I'm just set the company up
so I haven't got any company accounts or
anything so what was it about either
media about the situation what make look
that made you confident sunny leads
yes when I meet you I had a good feeling
that you'd be to be a good person to
work with so but I was kind of obviously
while are we meeting up and talking and
observing you all the way yeah I was
when you tell me everything
and I was willing to take the challenge
yeah and I didn't say to you you know
often in property for ten years
I'm a developer I didn't say that to you
I I was Lucas tell me I have something
to tell em thinking here we go when I
said to you I'll need to tell you
something about me myself and I was
about to tell you that I was actually
some your leads what did you think I was
gonna say I'm thinking oh my goodies
gonna do a deal here
yeah but the deal that I'm not gonna
like it oh really okay and you were
thinking I don't like the sounds of this
but oh well you know I'm always when I
told you that all the sub you leads
never come across to me that you're
gonna be yeah all this property
developer of property investor
yeah no so when I told you that my
actual track record and my experience in
poverty and I told you that I was
actually undercover starting from
scratch what did you think we surprised
I was surprised I know so it was quite
happy because at least someone someone
out there willing to do the job what you
doing it's gonna be you're gonna be a
role model to others yeah so other
people gonna think if he can do that why
why not yeah that's so true I'll be
saying we've if I give you a chance and
then I may learn from you yeah which I
have done learn a lot from me for seven
days yeah so much this week and what
advice would you give to somebody who
was wanting to make friends and build
trust with letting agents and wanting to
do deals things like that we've done
what advice would you give to them be
open-minded your boyfriend go for it
yeah
have to have the conversations have
conversation have confidence in yourself
trust is very very important
yeah because it's the end be honest
that's really no one yeah be honest
because if you now - nobody will trust
you because I think it's sometimes you
might speak to an agent and tell them
about the idea of doing a corporate
elect service accommodation and they
might say oh we don't do that my choice
is good yeah he's scared to try a new
things it's like me I'm not scared yeah
we get if we fail we fell together yeah
yeah and it was actually even the day
before we picked up the keys yeah rather
than me thinking oh my god I'm gonna try
the landlord if you remember I said how
to see how how is strong you are do you
really want this yeah are you oh so you
were kind of disarming a little bit hard
for me to see whether one could very
happy with you and explain to me what
you told him that we're gonna be renting
out of serviced accommodation there's
gonna be keypads outside yes he did
so what remote from the landlords point
of view why do you think this is a
win-win for the landlord well he
actually first time that I told him he
wasn't keen on the ideas however and he
think he see the bright side of it he's
asset to him I'm willing to try if
you're willing to try it if he works
which is good if he doesn't we know
we're not gonna cross that bridge again
yeah so at least we have tried so he
said okay I like the idea so let's do it
again from his point of view he's
getting six hundred a month he's doing
what he wants
he's not gonna have any hassle you're
getting your food for being what's that
sorry well because the landlord here is
absolutely down to no we have no issues
really love the game and then from my
point of view in fact when you found out
and I've now seen exactly what I'm going
to be doing yet you said to me I like
that myself
exactly yeah I've been thinking through
it because the hotels in Sheffield are
always fault Sheffield sometimes it's
not up to high Sunday yeah like here you
get everything exactly so wins
we've done our research up just on this
new bedroom apartment we're expected to
be able to rent this out for about 120
pound a night now obviously we've got
costs we've got pipe cleaners we've got
paid bookings not belong and all that
yeah that just in all the bells there's
still the profit at the end of the month
it's a good very healthy
I recommended it so anyone to do yeah
right rent to serviced accommodation we
call thinking them now as well yeah yes
so number one some of the hardships when
I was the day that I viewed this
property with you on your Monday my
yellow car broke down on the morning
yeah absolute disasters in the car so we
were very very very c-can't when I came
into because I have no money
as Lukas Ruby when I came into the
office to CC yes when I go into the
office to secure the the deal and I had
to pay the money over actually didn't
have the money mmm-hmm so I had to just
pretend to make the payment and this and
then say awesome thank you very much and
then I had to go sell HMO deal to get
the money to put down for the for the
property so it was it was
for this because I had to do it as Lukas
Ruby yeah from scratch so I had to get
the money in so in the end we did it and
we actually had eight thousand pounds so
we paid for these two properties we had
three thousand left with least the
furniture and yeah this morning we're in
Manchester we've given two thousand
pounds to a homeless charity this
morning Lucas all worked alliant why
because I am quite well known in the
prompting a lot of state agents and
certainly a lot of property investors
know so far we know but somehow it's
angle leads then when people watch the
show they'll say are the only reason
they did business with him is because
they know who they yes so if I'm Lucas
yeah but if I'm Lucas Ruby then there's
no excuses no mermaid no network stars
and completely from scratch what what
made you trust
Lucas Ruby he didn't have anything to
show I didn't trust him no some asset to
him over the phone I don't want to waste
your time I don't wanna waste my time
yeah other people time so I show you
around the puppet a modern welcome
- see well but you begin with but you
did trust me when you let me do the deal
in reply yes so what made you trust me
yeah that's the introduce yourself and
you handing a paperwork that I can do a
checks on you yeah and I did a checks
and I know who you are
yeah everything else that's why I but
before you even leave all the sunny will
leads when you thought was really
between before I did the reveal when I
said Tijuana securities my company's
brand-new and everything that we still
had rapport and you were like okay let's
do this so what why is that ii see on
you and sometimes i had a good judgment
people because obviously on these on
this job yeah you meet different
background people on different so you
had you had a good good feeling this
point you're not having any credit
checks or anything like that i didn't
have any money but you could go feeling
i don't decide let's give him a shot
yes I always give people a chance
because like I said in this job you make
people from different background I've
experienced some good and bad I used to
I used not puppeteer in Merseyside area
yeah Murr Society is not the best place
in Liverpool yeah
which you'll be dealing in different
background other people there yeah you
have to be open-minded yeah had fourth
influx so you've got a lot of experience
in the game so yes you know that's the
reason why I do all the viewings I do
all the inspections we do inspection and
a puppet the every four months and then
he goes to six months I do old
inspections because you have a big
judgment that's why that's very very
important
I don't hand it over to Richard or to
sue Sally
although Trustin yeah I still so the key
is for people what because really he was
not an hour and haven't got you know
million power
the bank or a really good proven
track-record misses everything maybe
just I now they need to find estate
agents that have good judgment where
they can come in and this is what I can
offer just go for it's not all of us got
a million some way no I've been God say
yeah we have to be open-minded most
people you have to give me a chance
yeah today to be up there next thing
fantastic I think it's a good idea what
you doing because I'm sure it's a lot of
people will be watching this I'm gonna
be thinking oh well you will help a lot
of people to get into property mother
yeah and it shows that anyone can do it
no excuses no excuse no money in you
coordinators Prive as long you are
determined to do what you want wanted to
do and you will get their patience and
just beat affirming like what I do
myself
I'm tastic what's your plans then moving
forward as your letting agency grows why
because you've got a lovely team I've
met Sally I met Richard I've met some of
the guys so you've got a really good
team that you've employed a new set up
so what the business of trusting all the
way and I know those people a long long
time so do you know I know you're gonna
work hard and they're gonna be there
yeah all the way yeah and you've been
inspired to do something similar
serviced accommodation so women when are
you going to be starting that probably
I'm actually exciting the ideas I've
been thinking throughout the widow think
yes actually I could do it this easily
well I want to say as well really from
bottom of my heart because when I came
to Sheffield at home and I only had one
week booked in my hotel and after that I
would have been evicted or would have
been on the streets so if it wasn't for
you I wouldn't have been able to achieve
my financial freedom challenge so thank
you for believing in me even
you didn't know my track record yes
thank you for your friendship and I'm
really looking forward to being in touch
thank you so much
[Music]